[Musique]
oui, à la maison
avec qui je veux que tout cela se termine
ou pensez-vous que c'est un supplément de plus parce que
ils donnent trop de brochure
ils mettent trop de pression sur l'un et
Je sens que c'est quelque chose ou c'est très difficile
parce que c'est un boulot de plus
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et
[Musique]
plus loin
définitivement cinq six sept huit
les heures à l'écran n'allaient pas marcher non
ils n'ont pas fonctionné pour nous au début non plus et
maintenant ce genre de modalité comme
scolairement pas un tuteur à domicile quoi
ce qui a fonctionné pour nous nous a aidés
afin qu'ils continuent d'avancer dans leur
éducation
Non
pour eux, c'est beaucoup plus important dans
cette étape socialiser ce qu'il faut apprendre
parce que l'apprentissage tu le portes bien
et l'accompagner tout au long du jeu pour
à travers la vidéo du livre d'observation
mais tu n'apprends pas cette coexistence
via des plateformes virtuelles
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
emmener la fille l'emmener dans un
pépinière maintenant ce n'est pas possible et il y a
moments où je dois l'apporter
endroit où je travaille
mais cela s'est produit dans plusieurs régions mais
Je pense que dans cette région on le voit encore
allez, on estime qu'au moins trois
des millions d'enfants dans notre région
il ne retournera jamais en classe plus il
allonger moins ce délai de fermeture
il y a de fortes chances que beaucoup d'enfants
revenir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]